forsen davos tribune
wai comme on dit war war dinner by
le calendrier a toujours été et ira
de sorte qu'ils étaient les gens veulent toujours
manger toujours
[musique]
explosion bien, tout a commencé à tomber pour s'effondrer
les vitres s'effritent, mais on va tout de suite au sous-sol ou
assis là pendant vingt minutes, puis
peu à peu commencé à sortir pour regarder
le spectacle est là
retour au travail nettoyer le verre
pour le moment ce n'est qu'un travail qui par
le fait est nécessaire pour tout le monde
trace alimentaire depuis la plupart
établissements au moins au début de la guerre
couvert pour couper mes actions mais je
J'ai senti que j'avais besoin de travailler
genre de qui sinon nous quelque chose comme
tel
c'est pourquoi je ne suis pas parti et j'ai décidé
au moins je ne le fais pas et je le ferai
continuer à travailler et à travailler
tu étais tu devais trouver un endroit où seulement où
obtenir mais ensuite trouver des fournisseurs trouvés
tous ces huit d'autres villes ici